en le bon bilan de rsa et bénévolat dans
le haut-rhin l'idée avait fait polémique
à l'origine l'an dernier en quatre mois
500 allocataires ont signé des contrats
d'engagement il passe quelques heures
dans des associations ou des
collectivités lorrain est le seul
département à le proposer en france
écouter la présidente du conseil
départemental
le premier bilan est vraiment très bon
bilan chiffré mais aussi bilan
qualitatif
les bénévoles les nouveaux bénévoles que
nous sommes allés trouver sont heureux
parce que c'était c'est pour eux une
entrée dans la vie active même si ça
n'est pas un emploi c'est pour eux une
possibilité peut-être demain grâce aux
contacts qui se crée grâce aussi à et
bien aux horaires retrouver puisque le
matin on se lève et on a un objectif
dans la vie c'est pour eux il estime que
c'est une chance pour eux